there's a new poll from Gallup which
confirms that Americans are very very
skeptical of Donald Trump's ability to
actually be President a majority of
Americans do not believe that Donald
Trump would be able to handle an
international crisis 47% of Americans
doubt Donald Trump's ability to use
military force wisely what gave you that
impression his lack of understanding of
why dropping nuclear weapons on Europe
would be bad I'm shocked that it's only
47% that doubt Trump's ability to use
the military wisely 44% of Americans
believe that Trump will not be able to
avoid major scandals during his
presidency and for comparison for
context Americans roughly had a 70%
belief that President Obama President
George W Bush President Bill Clinton
would do well in those areas and Trump's
numbers very very low our fearless
leader even where he did well in this
poll Trump didn't do as well as his
predecessor so for example the American
people have 60% confidence that Trump
will be able to work effectively with
Congress the American people have 59
percent confidence that Trump will
manage the economy well and here's the
key statistic for me Donald Trump will
enter office on January 20th with less
support than President Obama will leave
office with who is by the way at the top
of his presidential approval it's not
surprising to me Trump can't handle
Saturday Night Live skits about him
doesn't exactly project confidence about
dealing with important international
affairs you have actors on TV that are
triggering Twitter meltdowns from the
president-elect who would see that and
say this is the guy Pat that I trust to
deal with a terrorist attack when he's
triggered by Alec Baldwin on 11:30
Saturday night television
well definitely the minority of people
but if you look also at the presidential
job approval numbers usually at the very
beginning of a term it's at or near the
highest I mean Obama had it in the high
60s George W Bush even though he lost
the popular vote the first time around
it was around 60% yep
Trump is starting off at around 40%
there's no telling how low it'll go now
there will be so how would the trumpets
explain that it always a relevant
question they would say there has been a
coordinated smear campaign combined with
more polarization than we've ever seen
and of course corporate media and and
and liberal media telling lies that of
course people are being influenced into
thinking these things about Donald Trump
that's how the Trump ascends it and it
is true that we have an acutely
polarized America right now but when you
look at what what Pat is pointing out in
terms of past approval ratings things
have been pretty polarized in the United
States for a very long time and I would
even go further George W Bush after 9/11
I don't remember if it was eighty or
ninety five or ninety percent as it may
have been approval rating you don't get
to 90 percent approval with no Democrat
saying we approve of what you're doing
the high approval rating that George W
Bush had disappeared and crumbled into
one of the most historically low
approval ratings not because of
polarization it was because of what
George W Bush did and I think that while
on the one hand yes Americans are very
very influenced by media narratives and
talking points and memes on the internet
to some degree they do react to what
people candidates elected officials
actually do now there's a real serious
issue here which is when I think about
it with what we know about Donald
Trump's attention span with what we know
about Donald Trump's disregard for the
laborers that built his buildings how
Donald Trump treats women I wouldn't
trust Donald Trump to supervise the
fryer at a fast-food restaurant I don't
know that he could even keep track of
the oil temperature keeping things clean
breaks for the line cooks and it you
know whatever the case may be I
genuinely think Rachel that if he was
put in that position I don't know that
he could actually figure it out and run
that mini little business I definitely
don't think he couldn't it's kind of
reminiscent of his ghostwriter from the
art of the deal yeah saying torts yes
who is saying that his attention to
detail his attention span and he
a high level of inflammatory responses
to very small instances is quite
frightening
yeah Tony Schwartz the article if you
haven't read this article it's from
before the election but it's a great
read Tony Schwartz said number one there
was always a TV on in the background in
the room when he was talking to Trump
and he would be looking for a second at
Tony Schwartz who's trying to write
Trump's book mind you and he would just
get distracted and be looking at the TV
and start talking about what's on the TV
Tony Schwartz in talking to Trump
learned that Trump basically does not
read and said he would be shocked to
hear that Trump had read ace a single
book a single book covered a cover in
the last 40 years of his life Ben Dixon
and Pat actually on last last week when
I was away had a really great segment
about buyer's remorse going on with
Trump and that is super common there's
two groups of Trumpets as I see it
there's the fully committed Trumpets who
will never turn away from Trump but then
there's the more reluctant and skeptical
Trumpets who didn't want to vote for
Hillary Clinton said well I'm not gonna
stay home I'm not gonna do a third party
vote if there is a rift between
establishment Republicans in Congress
and Trump that is only going to
exacerbate the risk rift between the
committed Trumpets and the ones who were
a little bit more sane and logical and
again that could be the environment in
which progressives can really get in the
way of trumps nonsense yeah because
there were so many people who voted for
Donald Trump who were otherwise
Republicans and he was just the last one
remaining yeah or they were just so put
off by Hillary Clinton that he was their
only other option yeah I mean you know
maybe it's a 50/50 split but if there's
20 percent of those people are remaining
that's gonna be a very low approval
number what what I know is that whether
it's 50/50 or 2080 or whatever the split
is between the committed trumpets and
the reluctant Trump Republicans those
who start to break away from Trump's
policies are going to do it loudly they
are going to have a presence in media
and we're absolutely going to know about
it
Warby Parker is offering a free five day
home Tryon to give you the opportunity
to check out their glasses I personally
wear Warby Parker glasses when I'm not
wearing my contact lenses and I also
started with one of these free at home
try ons of five pairs of glasses you can
get your free home try on and support
the david pakman show at Warby Parker
trialed dot-com slash TDPS I don't
really like going into glasses stores
and trying on glasses while the
salesperson sort of hovers over me and I
like more than 30 seconds to actually
figure out whether I like the glasses so
with the Warby Parker home Tryon I was
able to pick five pairs that I liked put
them on in the comfort of my own home
pick the one I liked the most and then
Warby Parker put my prescription lenses
in there for me a lot of people don't
know that the eyeglass industry is
controlled by just a few big
corporations that keep prices very high
like three hundred dollars for
prescription glasses high which is just
insane Warby Parker glasses start at $95
that's what mine cost and for every pair
of glasses sold Warby Parker distributes
a pair of glasses to someone in need you
can try five pairs and see what you like
check out the at home trial and support
our show by going to Warby Parker comm
slash TDP s it costs nothing